really really
excited to be here it's always a
pleasure to be back on campus
i think we need more opportunities to
come back uh
but thanks a lot for the lovely
introduction and uh and for those of you
who did not raise your hands you have
about an hour to download pulse
because i want a full full raise of
hands in the the end of the
presentation uh but today
uh so hi i'm ankit uh i'm akshay
we met at stanford uh became really
really good friends
and and started pulse in the last
quarter of our
first studies of our grad school uh here
and
today we're here to talk about a topic
that's really really near and dear to
our hearts
uh all of us uh in school
and when we're bored of what we're
actually doing do side projects
and that's kind of a way where you know
we either do them for a grade or we
do them just to have fun but i don't
know how many of you it was definitely
not the case for
for us stop and think about the side
projects right
like you know why are you doing this why
what is what is actually the real driver
and
and how is this in a way kind of
improving your life or
helping you in the future right and we
did that for ourselves
uh you know just after we launched pulse
and realized that there's a huge amount
of value
in doing side projects today here here
we are
to talk about side projects and how uh
you know should start taking them
seriously um
and and these are just some quick
projects that we're going to put in
front of you
that we have done in our last uh in in
the two years that we were in school
um and you know we'll tell you
we'll take you through our journey and
share with you why those side projects
did not work
uh and what were the learnings behind
that and how we
you know in addition to a lot of
learnings how we used those
uh and really applied that to pulse and
uh
and kind of turned it uh turned into an
advantage
uh for us so the first one
this is an app that uh i worked on
uh during my summer internship between
my first and second year
uh with a friend called evan reyes who
is currently the founder of circle
and it was called buzzword the idea was
really really simple
uh iphone 3gs had just launched at that
time
and the biggest change in the iphone
series was the ability to take videos
and so we were like yeah a lot of people
would start taking videos because it's
there
uh and what will they do with those
videos right and so we were creating a
platform where
you can get you can see all the videos
that people are taking
and the goal was oh it'll be on a map
where uh
you'll see what's happening right now
like people will be taking a lot of
videos about
uh some celebrity sighting or some
restaurant that opened up
or uh this is where things start going
downhill
but you can see all these videos on a
map and you'll be able to spot what's
happening
and the business model was that an
advertiser will be able to
promote their product or service that is
that someone has taken a video about
which we were hoping was you know quite
frequent
uh that was not the case um and so
this was the idea we tried you know we
had a lot of conversation a lot of
debate about it took us two months to
launch
and eventually we did that and it failed
it
it got you know 200 downloads in the
first day
got 20 downloads in the second day maybe
like two
the rest of the days that week and then
it really didn't get any downloads after
that um
and and the biggest learning that i had
from that was you need to focus
on we we did we just had an idea that
people will
you know use take a lot of videos and
and
want to see them on a map right that was
just a cool idea we didn't actually have
a solution
for something that's a problem that
users were facing
uh and the big learning was that you
need to focus on solutions
not ideas all of us here are really
creative
and we come up with loads of ideas
throughout the day and we can we become
really excited about that
and say dude we should start a company
around that but that's when you actually
go to the other side where you talk to
where you you know find out what someone
um
actually a problem problem that they
have and solve that
is is when uh you know real value comes
out
this project was a class project that
a couple friends and i did in our
computer vision course
uh it was a really really fun course uh
was taught by sebastian thrun at that
time
um and you know it was it was a regular
crafts project that we were doing for a
grade
and at the same time i was also taking
some other d school classes
and so i was really excited about um
about you know making it as a product
not just a
class project uh and so convince my
teammates we went and um you know talked
to a lot of people and kind of looked at
uh what computer vision problems can be
solved right and so we eventually got to
this
this project where you can sit in front
of a computer
and uh try on pairs of glasses
and so as you can see these are not
glasses this is just the rendering
but the essential concept was that say
warby parker has a
has a website and you can just sit there
in front of your camera
and you can move your head around and
try glasses
uh because you know i i have a pair of
glasses and it's really hard for me when
i go to a store
and i take these off and then i put on
another pair and i have to like stare at
the mirror
uh to actually see how i look in those
glasses because i can't see without my
glasses
so that was the idea at that time um
but again it was
it just got to a class project and it
and it failed
uh for a bunch of reasons because it was
hard to get the technology right
it would have taken us a lot of time and
it was a very crowded market
but essentially the learning there was
which we stumbled
uh upon very fortunately was we were
slowly moving from just thinking of it
as a class project for
a grade to an actual startup it was
almost as if you know we do
at least in computer science there are
three to four courses that a graduate
student takes and every course
has a project usually and so when we
started thinking about
each of these projects as potential
startups that we could
launch regardless of whether the startup
actually launched or not
you went through a lot of different
ideas you met with a lot of different
people
and you actually trained your mind in
how to
accept certain parts of an idea how to
reject certain parts of an idea the best
way
to communicate that to people and so on
so the more
projects that you that we did as as
startups
the better we got at training ourselves
to really really do it when
when you know we wanted to uh afterwards
this third project is
is actually part of a research that i
was doing at stanford uh
and so when i came here uh in 2008
i had just come from india directly and
i had no scholarship or
or any kind of grant and it wasn't
really exciting to think of taking that
much of a loan
and and trying to repay that later so
the first thing i did was try to get a
research position
at stanford and i was really lucky i uh
did this project in the radiology
department and it was a really really
cool project it was about using image
processing
on scans to detect the type of breast
cancer
and so without doing an actual surgery
you can just look at the scan
and try to classify what kind of cancer
a person has and so initially it was a
really exciting project
but you know throughout my first year
kind of towards the end
i i got slightly bored of the project
and the other things that i could have
done with my time like meeting new
people
coming up with new ideas or trying out
new prototypes
all of those things where i wasn't able
to do that this this project was cutting
into that
but on the flip side i was able to
actually pay my tuition and be
at stanford because of this project uh
and so it was a really
mind-boggling trade-off like in
hindsight it seems very simple
but it was very difficult and i
struggled with that almost towards the
end of my
uh two years uh when in my last quarter
i decided hey
this is not worth it i actually want to
i want to value my time so essentially
the big learning was
time is more valuable than money and so
i took all of the earnings that i had
it was about five to six thousand
dollars and
uh spent it on tuition food
uh rent and basically spent that money
on
um on that d school class that we
started pulse
uh and so all of my time was focused on
this one course
one product and one idea that we had
and that obviously paid out really well
um but essentially the learning was like
your time
is is way more valuable than other
things that people tell you
are actually valuable and that also
applies when
when you do a startup uh where there are
a million decisions you have to do
um you know when we launched pulse there
was a client ready to pay
thirty thousand 000 uh during our first
month
but we decided not to pursue that
instead carry out
uh kind of working on our roadmap
because we knew we were building
something a lot more valuable
um so that's number three i'll pass on
to akshay for for the rest
yeah so i wanted to kind of talk
similarly on three projects i worked at
stanford
like on kit uh in my two years and i
learned a lot
uh from it so this was one of the first
my first project
that i kind of thought let's let's take
it out there this was the
a project i did with a couple of friends
in my summer between my first and second
year
um uh and we actually got a grant at
light speed uh to basically you know
i think we got about thirty thousand
dollars to kind of build this app and
actually push it out
and a simple idea we had was that uh we
we saw our people kind of
uh at least in stanford like running
late to meetings or
um running late or and still driving and
you want to kind of just kind of
push out your phone and you know say i'm
a few minutes late and then the text
message goes so it was a very simple app
that we actually built where you can
actually see the contacts up there
and you can kind of select like a set
message and and then just send it
in like you know without actually typing
any message and we actually launched it
i think this app still exists and i
don't know what's happening to it but
it actually taught me a lot of
interesting things which i didn't
realize um i think when when i did this
project
i was actually in the frame of mind
where i was really thinking about
starting a company
like doing a startup being an
entrepreneur like those things were
really important to me and then
the summer when i kind of went through
that i realized that that actually adds
a lot of pressure on you
you suddenly feel like oh i'm an
entrepreneur i'm doing the startup
and it kind of like moves you away from
thinking about the core
thing that you're actually working on
which is working on products like i
think that
working on product is a lot simpler a
lot easier to think about rather than
thinking about
i want to do a startup i want to be an
entrepreneur and actually during the
startup i learned a lot about
founder dynamics we actually had four
founders and during that summer we
actually had to fire one founder
and we we made all sorts of mistakes in
terms of like how we should think about
equity
how we should think about legal stuff
like how we should think about
product and actually just kind of this
app that we actually
spent almost 10 weeks building you know
we didn't think any
anything about marketing we just kind of
put it on the app store
and thought we would get thousands and
thousands of downloads
um you know that never happens you have
to really think about like how is this
going to be positioned in the market how
are you going to market it
what are some of the things you're going
to do so that people actually discover
it
um so anyways that summer ended and i
came back to stanford because
you know this wasn't really going
anywhere but i came back with all these
learnings about
if i were to you know if i were to start
a company or if i were working on a
product that's taking off
it's gonna i know exactly how i should
think about
equity uh between my founders i should
how do you structure the legal stuff
well so that you know
we don't have that so all of that was
really key learnings for this
the second project that i did was
actually in rwanda
which was part of the class called
extreme affordability at stanford
it's offered at the design school and it
was really fascinating because i i did
my undergrad in electrical engineering
and
also my master's in electrical
engineering where we kind of sit in a
class
and where we you know we get problems we
spend a lot of time in labs
we kind of like talk to some peers we
kind of solve problems
on paper and give it to them i remember
my first project at d school was
uh to redesign how people eat ramen
noodles
and i was like these guys must be
kidding like
redesigning ramen noodles like it's fine
the way it is and they pushed us to go
out there and observe
people eating ramen noodles uh and they
pushed us to kind of go to markets and
see what people
kind of buy and i found that really
really like
awkward at the first time like i
remember i was at maruichi in mountain
view
and i was just kind of like staring at
people eating ramen noodles
and i was like
they must be thinking i'm i'm some sort
of a freak
doing that and i was thankfully with
another couple of people who
who started talking about oh you know
that person like the water is kind of
you know coming out of the bowl that
person is kind of eating while he's
walking
and you start seeing people like doing
things that they do
but their problems with the way they're
doing it um
and so when we when we did the when i
did the extreme course we were trying to
essentially
improve nutrition for rwanda and
thinking about
how are we going to actually uh improve
the nutrition in the country where a lot
of people actually diet because they
don't have enough nutrition
and it's one thing to think about okay
well we want to try nutrition so we have
these 10 ideas
but there's another thing where you
actually go out there and you spend 10
days
it's actually sitting with with these
people like we spent 10 days in rwanda
on the ground
really understanding you know how they
live what they eat
you know what is their daily process
what are the things they actually do
and how does our solution fit into their
daily life so that we're not actually
trying for a
huge behavioral change um and this was a
huge learning for me because
you know this is a project i was doing
alongside courses like
uh machine learning and courses like
artificial intelligence where we don't
get this
experience but i think in this case just
getting that knowledge you know really
understanding how people live is very
important for
actually building your next you know
building your products because you
really
need to know how people currently live
and what people currently do and what
problems they have
before you go out there and actually
build something for them
and then it's kind of started to come
all together in some ways where
um this is the project ankit and i
actually did
with a friend albert in the data
visualization class
where this was an idea that you know we
a lot of people wanted to kind of
visualize their lives in
in in kind of a timeline and this was
actually
we actually use the facebook api and
build this timeline two years before
they introduce their timeline
so if you actually like rotate this 90
degrees like it's the facebook timeline
uh but we actually built this in our
class and this was
this was where it started to come
together where we actually
talked to a lot of people uh who used
facebook on campus or in cafes in palo
alto and started talking to them in
terms of how they would want to
visualize their lives
and we would build this in a couple of
weeks really fast
you know rapid prototyping where all
your facebook data was put on a timeline
you could kind of
browse down there over the last two
years you could actually search for a
person and see
what kind of interactions you've had
with them it was just a neat tool that
actually was appreciated by a lot of
people who were in the class and who
actually got to see this um
it was also the time where i started
started to feel like
all the classes that i'd taken at these
school which taught me
uh going out there speaking to people
getting insights from them
and then tying it back to the knowledge
we get from computer science and
electrical engineering courses
in terms of actually building tools
started to come together
where we were starting to do both of
them together um
and in this case like you know just kind
of being able to build something quickly
like i think this was a key learning for
me before coming to stanford i had
you know i had a lot of ideas in my head
but i didn't do anything about it
and i realized one thing is that your
your i think your head can only
take only keep so many ideas and so if
you want to actually
bring new more new ideas to yourself you
actually need to do something about your
current idea so that
either it works and you go for it or it
doesn't work and it's out of your head
so that you have space for new ideas to
come in
and i actually really believe that i
think like you can't
you know otherwise you're just kind of
you have five ideas and you think
all of them are like a billion dollar
ideas but you're not doing anything
about it
but actually like even spending two
weeks four weeks or even a day
like prototyping something and realizing
whether this has some wheels or not
is is key to figuring you know kind of
continuing to
iterate and so like these you know there
are three of my projects unkid talked to
you know three of his projects these six
projects actually like
you know taught us a lot of interesting
things in stanford
just in these two years just through
class projects and we
we learned a lot about finding need like
what do people really want we found
a lot about you know what's the value of
time at this stage when we're in our
early 20s
uh like is this more valuable than
actually like spending time on other
things that we're less passionate about
i you know we learned a lot about
founder dynamics like how important it
is to
keep it simple to have good
kind of transparent feedback for each
other and given i've worked for
you know we over four years but we
worked for pulse over the last three
years and
it's been really really important for us
to like when i have a problem
to just call ankit for lunch and tell
him that hey like you know
you know what you did here was not right
i i didn't like that
you know in the future let's make sure
we're always in sync or for him to tell
me that
you know it would be nice if you could
hear me out a little bit more
i think like just the dynamics is
extremely important because at the end
of the day
you know what you're building as a
startup it's it's all about people
and the people really need to click need
to work together and collaborate
so for me to actually make some of those
mistakes in the first summer actually
was
hugely important um for for for when
we've actually built pulse
and then kind of goes to go on with like
you know a lot we still go out
every friday and talk to a lot of people
understand how
are they reading news today like what
are you doing what kind of sources are
you reading
where are you reading it um how many
times in the day do you read news
all of those actually help us figure out
what are the products we're going to
build
and so all of that actually led to the
last quarter at stanford where we
actually built pulse
uh which i was really pleased that about
half the room kind of knew about it
but we built this as uh you know all
those learnings came together we built
the first version of pulse again in a
d-school class in five weeks
um it was an ipad app we built it in
five weeks put it on the app store
and it kind of took off in a big way uh
and and so the last three years
we've been really focused on kind of
expanding that vision expanding the
product
and today actually having an app that's
you know used by over 30 million people
um has been you know kind of a
culmination of all of these
learnings that we've had over over the
two years we were at stanford
um to a point where now we're actually
employees of linkedin
because linkedin bought us about two
weeks ago for 30 mil
for 90 million dollars um and so
i think for a lot of that i think people
can say that
or you know sometimes we can think of it
as like oh you know
they came up with this idea for in five
weeks they put it on the app store
and then just this kind of just became
you know this this huge success
uh but actually it was there was a lot
of small pieces at stanford
that actually made it possible small
things we learned in
in these in these site projects
and the more site projects you do the
more mistakes you make
the more learning you have and you never
know when that side project is going to
become a big company
but if you stay focused on actually
building products
if you stay focused on actually just
kind of putting things out there
seeing how people use it seeing if
there's something interesting
you might actually be sitting on
something that's you know the next big
product that that may make it out there
um so so we wanted to kind of keep that
short uh
um kind of talk to you about like some
of the things we've learned but
uh you know really open it up to
questions you guys have um
we were here just over three years ago
listening to people and we thought that
you know one of the things i
i realized was like i wanted to ask more
questions and kind of you know
think about things or ask questions
particular things that you know
you don't hear otherwise and so ankit
and i are very happy to be very
transparent about all the things
we did at stanford good or bad uh that
really helped us
actually build pulse um to where it is
today
so let's open up to any questions you
guys have yeah
go for
so what were it of the things that well
how did you learn
what was working and what wasn't working
quickly
yeah so are you knocked a little bit
about what we did with pulse um
so with pulse it was it was
because it was built in five weeks it
was very bare bones
i did the visual design as an electrical
engineer so you can imagine how bad it
was initially
and so
i i i'm glad we're not sharing those
mocks anywhere
but it was it was actually pretty bad
and we were not sure if it was ready for
prime time
and so what we did was we we actually
thought let's target a smaller
demographic first
so we did was we actually uh my good
friend joel had this really cool camera
and we said can we just
shoot a film of about a minute which
basically goes through the app
and shows what it can do and and so we
we we shot this at satora cakes in palo
alto which actually is not there anymore
but we shot it there and we put this
video in a bunch of design blogs out
there
so we put it in course 77 not caught
not the tech blogs we put it more in the
design blogs just to
see people's reactions to it and
more design blocks picked up that video
and so
already we saw a lot of people actually
uh
curious about this app so even before we
actually launched it on the app store
people were actually talking about it
people found the interaction to be
really neat
and and so so that was the first thing
and then we actually launched it without
actually press
just to see how real people use it and
we actually saw the app actually shoot
up to the top of the news category
but there was a lot of feedback like the
visual design was really bad
people wanted more sources they wanted
to add people wanted a better catalog
and so we spent another two weeks
actually refining the product
to those feedback points and that
getting that feedback quickly was really
important for us
and then when we felt comfortable we
actually sat down with a visual designer
for a full day who basically like took
out all my designs and actually made it
much
cleaner like you see in these mocks um
and then we
actually did a smart thing we actually
made another video
but in this video we actually focused on
sources that we wanted
us to wanted to cover us or like so we
focused on like we had techcrunch in
there we had new york times in there
we had a bunch of sources there um
impulse
being used and then we actually emailed
techcrunch and said
see techcrunch is featured in this video
uh we emailed new york times and said
you're featured in this video um
this is a new product that stanford
students have built like you guys may
want to cover
us um simple simple
and then and then they picked up that
video so techcrunch actually wrote about
it
they wrote about it and then we actually
shot to the top of the app store
uh overall not just the news category
and then
new york times picked up because they
said well there's a class project that's
suddenly the top of the app store
and so we were that was that was you
know the first week when we actually got
you know more mainstream press but we
were actually ready at that time
to be able to kind of accommodate you
know a much bigger use
user base as well
could you please tell me a little bit
about the team and how it
uh expanded and what you learned during
that
yeah process think uh that's actually
one of the big benefits of being at
stanford
uh a lot of the people that you meet
here eventually become part of your
startup family uh like the very first
engineer that we hired so i
akshay uh was more on the design side
i did the original ios apps and the very
first engineer we hired was albert
and the three of us did the the last
project that you saw together
and albert did the the android app and
then slowly we built out a team where we
hired
uh greg who was our lead back-end
engineer uh who had worked with akshay
before
um on the previous startup like the zap
text one i actually worked with him so i
actually pulled him back
into a more successful one yeah and then
we hired uh christina
who who i think utad
in one of the courses and through a lot
of like friend ta network
uh we we got a lot of our early hires
uh yeah actually first seven eight
people were all from stanford
um because we at that time we we hadn't
raised a lot of money
uh we actually were not making a whole
lot and so
those were stanford people are the crazy
people who actually believe in you and
like
believe in your hope and actually join
you um and
and so we kind of got people who we were
we had worked before
or who are friends that they kind of
joined us and actually
and we got to a point where we actually
raised our seed round which is about a
million dollars
which allowed us to actually move into a
real office um
and then kind of slowly built it up i
think our hiring so far
i think we've we've tried to stay small
uh we were about 25 people
when linkedin acquired us um so it's you
know still tiny compared to the traffic
we had
but we our hiring strategy was more
about uh
actually hiding people after you feel
the pinch rather than really having that
foresight
that we may have this pain in the future
so
uh how many women i think we had about
seven or eight people seven or eight
women in the company uh we still do
thunder dynamics
how might
the question is how would the dynamics
be different if one of our co-founders
was
uh was a was female i think like for us
like ankit and i have actually
uh tried very hard to actually keep a
balance
uh in the company and actually having
women
be part of the team and the the reason
is actually there's a lot of good
reasons for it
but i think there's a lot of things that
i think that uh that a woman can think
that a man wouldn't think
or necessarily and especially for pulse
actually we're trying to build a product
which actually use is used by mainstream
people it's not built for just males who
are using
you know just reading about tech or
other things it's actually built for
anybody who wants to read about
you know content and so actually having
that dna in the company where
you know christina who's our first hire
uh to tell us like hey like
you know it's good we have text sources
but we also need to have fashion and
lifestyle and we also need to have
other things that people would read and
and so having that balance is really
good
the other thing that was really good for
from an internal culture perspective is
that
actually just people in general are much
more well behaved if they're like
you know if it's not just like 10 dudes
like in a company
men are well behaved yeah mostly men are
well i guess
so actually internal culture was uh was
hugely beneficial
and and it really helped us to hire more
more female employees so
we actually had uh gene who was our
first uh
our second android engineer and it was
really hard to see any other startups
have female engineers in their teams
which is great so
after the linkedin acquisition um what
are the
what are the sacrifices of penny that
you've had to make and what kind of
explorer
so today was my official third day at
linkedin so i'm still figuring out some
of those things
but i'll tell you this so
pulse actually had a lot of content a
lot of users uh but we were trying to
get identity which is basically like
you know who are these people reading
what's their background um and linkedin
on the other side has identity it has
over 220 million users
they know where they're working and
they're trying to get into content so
it's a very complimentary
uh kind of fit for both both teams and
linkedin has been really really
good in terms of keeping us keeping the
same culture that we have so we all sit
together at linkedin
we're still driving the pulse app uh but
suddenly we find ourselves actually
having a lot more resources
uh in terms of you know they have some
among the best machine learning
uh teams in the valley um they have
incredible mobile products and so just
being able to tap into them
like i think has been so far amazing but
we'll find out more as we kind of
you know fully integrate with them
have you ever thought consciously about
your culture i mean how would you
characterize your problems
yeah i can i can take it you should add
more but i think
culture is actually one of the most
important things um
that i think every founder should think
about um
and the interesting thing is like the
culture changes
you know very fast like with two people
like adding another person
can change it a fair bit and so culture
could be very different for four people
versus 10 people versus 20 people and so
you have to as
from a founder perspective you have to
always be changing processes
to make sure that everybody gets that
for us
actually we we borrowed we stole a lot
of ideas from d-school
uh and put it in two pulse and so
there are no cubes like it's open floor
everybody has access to everyone
it's a very transparent company um
they're post-its all around so you can
every person should be thinking about
product it's not just like
us or the product manager like even if
you're a backend engineer you should be
thinking about product a lot
um there's whiteboard walls uh so you
can just write anywhere any any space
can become a discussion space because
you never know who you're going to run
into and what
what serendipitous ideas kind of come
out
on fridays we have a session at the end
of friday
to wrap up the week we have a session
which we call
i like i wish i wonder which is again
stolen from the d school
but i think at d school what they used
to do is at the end of the class they
used to
you could sit down for 10 minutes and
give feedback to your professor
you could say like oh i like how you did
this or i wish this was taught in a
different way
and so we stole that and we made it our
debrief
uh internally which we still do today
every friday
every week and so people get together in
a big circle at pulse 25 people so we
started when we were five
but even at 25 we do this
where we gather around in a circle and
everybody gets a chance to say anything
on their mind
the only requirement is the the sentence
should start with i like
something i wish something or i wonder
something
um and so they could say like you know i
wish akshay
spoke less or i like ankit's dressing
sense or i wonder you know what
what's going to happen to pulse at
linkedin so it's a very open culture
in that way i
i wonder are you monetized both
great questions um so i think for
monetization uh
uh were it might change
depending because of the linkedin
acquisition but i think at the core
we're really excited about uh content
marketing
uh and in very simple terms content
marketing is essentially
allowing brands to be publishers to be
able to write their content
um and so you know red bull does this
really well where they have
they they sponsor a lot of events they
write a lot of interesting content that
people read
and so our core belief is that
advertising should not be annoying it
shouldn't feel like advertising it
shouldn't feel like the banners you see
on the web
it should feel like content it should
feel like something you want to actually
engage in
and pulse is all about content and so i
think our monetization
plan is to essentially uh just like you
can read
different publishers like brands will be
able to have a voice inside pulse as
well
girlfriend can you have any wisdom or
advice about
fundraising and like how you got
funds to especially during the initial
parts of your
um of the startup so the question was if
there's any wisdom around fundraising
i can yeah the best wisdom is that
hopefully you don't have to think about
it um
we didn't have to think about it so
essentially we stayed focused on product
and we got lucky in a couple of
different ways um
first was i think ankit and i built
pulse and we said
okay we're going to push this out for
free that was the first thing that i
think most people think
like oh yeah it's the valley push things
for free get lots of users
but we had a professor michael dearing
who said why are you giving such a
beautiful product for free
and i think we were thinking well this
looks really ugly
nobody's going to buy this but he said
no
you know i think we should ask people so
we actually went out to cafes and asked
them
you know how much would they actually
pay for it we got people actually saying
that they would actually pay three to
five dollars
so the first version of pulse actually
had a four dollar price tag
um which was awesome because suddenly we
i think in the first six months we sold
about a quarter million
uh of these copies so that was our first
million dollars
where we did not have to actually ask
investors for money
um and then we had enough traction then
we were ready to kind of
expand beyond that but investors were
actually asking us
uh whether they could invest so it's a
very enviable position and i think we
got a lot we got really lucky we're
really fortunate with pulse but in
general i think um
we can talk offline in terms of exact
dynamics that you should think about if
you are going out fundraising
uh in terms of what are some of the
things that work uh do not work
but if you stay focused on product
hopefully like people will notice that
and in today's world actually you don't
need that much money to start things
uh unless you're actually building
satellites uh which i don't know a
couple
weeks ago somebody spoke about that but
i think with a lot of consumer startups
you don't need
that much money so i think start
something out there push it out there
see if that
has wheels before you actually really
think about you know raising money
yeah and and the other thing that i
would add to that was uh
it was it was very good when we did
fundraising because akshay was more
focused on that whereas i was still
focused on the product
and usually it's the case that when
you're fundraising your product suffers
and if you let that happen then it
impacts your fundraising negatively also
so it's always very important to keep
the product going however you can
while you're in fundraising
perfect did you consider bootstrapping
all the way
we did we did so we had we so we sold
about a quarter of
a million um these apps it was you know
we had a few hundred thousand dollars in
the bank um
and we got to a point where we could
continue doing that
and that would you know that would have
hopefully like sold more and we would
have made
but i think we got to a point where um
a lot of the ideas in our heads was
actually built around the fact that
you know not just you but your friends
your family all of
you will be reading news on pulse and
your experience
will get even better when when when all
your people you're connected with also
read news on pulse
uh and and we got to a point also
personally where we decided that you
know
we kind of wanted we we had bigger
dreams we just didn't want to have like
a million dollar
uh that we split a few you know with
three four people and kind of run with
that
although there's nothing wrong with that
but i think personally
we we wanted to kind of really kind of
shoot for the fences with pulse
especially because this was the first
company that ankit and i
are you know seriously working for or
started
and so so we decided to kind of you know
take the take the leap
uh and actually do that
but but i think i mean i think we could
have actually stayed
bootstrapped and you know that could
have been an interesting kind of
trajectory for pulse as well
being here so obviously one of the a lot
of the traditional uh content publishers
and media companies are
facing a lot of challenges in terms of
monetizing their content or
having to switch to new monetization
channels um what are some of the
interesting or exciting ways you think
content publisher or content delivery
platforms like pulse can help with that
beyond just helping them reach like a
broader or more targeted leadership
so the question was like what's the
value proposition for publishers to be
on clear pulse there in terms of
leadership but what are some of the
exciting ways so you think you can help
them in terms of
monetization yeah it's monetization i
think for publishers i think
um so you know there's two value
propositions for them one is obviously
getting readership the other is making
money
and for making money i think there are
two bets we've made with
uh and and i think they've been pretty
interesting so i think
we did not have a background in
journalism or publishing and so we kind
of came in
really rethinking how advertising looks
and rethinking how commerce looks
for for these content publishers i've
talked a little bit about advertising
which is i think we think
content marketing is the future which is
essentially you know stop thinking of
ads as banners and something that
destroy the user experience we think of
ads as content that people want to read
about
so that's one piece the other piece that
we've thought about is commerce which is
essentially
we launched a partnership with wall
street journal where you could actually
buy
the best articles of today from wall
street journal for one dollar a month
and that was actually one of the most
innovative partnerships actually the
only time wall street journal has
actually
done a different partnership beyond
their own model and we actually got
convinced them to actually
do it for one dollar a month and the
idea there was
uh very simple which was basically if
you get a brand new iphone
um you know you you download a bunch of
free apps because they're easy to
you know install um but there comes a
time when you actually like actually put
in your credit card details and get that
one dollar app
i don't know if you guys have noticed
that but once you buy that one dollar
app
then like you're buying five dollar apps
and 20 apps and he was just kind of like
spending a lot on the platform and we
thought like we could take that idea and
bring it to the publishing world where
you know if you know also journal today
the first if you want to actually buy
something that would be about forty five
dollars a month or thirty or thirty five
dollars a month
that's a huge price point for people who
actually get free content you know
convincing them to actually pay 35 a
month is a lot and so we thought well
maybe we can prime them so that
people can actually buy something for
one dollar a month and those people
would actually
be great customers who could actually
buy full subscriptions also
um so we're in that strategy we're still
figuring out how that kind of plays out
for us
but you know that's that's the other
thing we've kind of experimented with
you mentioned that you have some
problems at the start and perhaps you
need to equip with equity
and uh if you have any recommendations
or suggestions for
speaking questions
i'll save you but i think like there's
there's a lot of i think the cool thing
about now is there's a lot of
information online
um and so i think you should definitely
read
every line of uh you know venture hacks
because it has everything in terms of
details of how these are structured
i think the other advice i would say
particularly with founders is actually i
actually think
one is extremely hard like just actually
being a single founder
i don't even know how a single founder
does it because there's so much stress
on a daily basis um two is actually
for me it's been ideal like just working
with anketh has been really fun because
there's been times when like i've been
really really like you know hit
low uh in terms of like all the things
that went wrong today
and on kids like in a medium and so we
kind of like balance each other
and then there's been times that i'm
kids kind of hit low and i'm doing okay
because
maybe the sales are okay and so i think
two has been really good for us in terms
of just kind of balancing each other's
energy
um i think beyond two i think
three is probably still okay but i think
four is too many
um and so actually like keeping your
founders to maybe two
ideally or three is is is good because
then i think
you know you have a couple brains to
think about uh
you know someone to argue something if
your only founder it might not have
enough people to kind of really bounce
ideas off of
but with four actually um
we were thinking about like our personal
issues more than we were thinking about
ideas
about the startup right i think there
were i think it was just too many
cooks in the kitchen at that point yeah
and the founder culture
becomes really important right that that
actually creates the company culture in
some sense and
that's why being very transparent with
each other being
giving open feedback being constructive
about each other's ideas
and all of that uh happens very smoothly
when you're two people
but when you're three or or more just it
just breaks down because there's
too many connections happening yeah i
think like open feedback is really key
i think like ankit and i started that in
the first two months when we were
working alone and actually like in the
company everybody can give feedback
we have an internal form called aaa
which is essentially like ask
akshay and ankit anonymously which is
this
which is this like simple anonymous
google form which anybody in the company
can ask random questions to us like
i don't know like why are the toilets
not working and then
what happens in board meetings what
happens in board meetings and ankit and
i
have to answer that every friday so
every friday before we do i like i wish
i wonder we actually
go through all the questions people have
asked um and everybody has access to
this doc
so they can see all the questions that
other people are asking
um and then i think that open feedback
loop is really really important
because uh i think one of the ways i
think about it
is that you know these like small
tremors
like are good for the earth like you
don't want
kind of the pressure to build and have a
massive earthquake right like you want
this
kind of you want the pressure to be
released every now and then so that
you don't actually have a kind of a big
outlash against anyone
can you please tell us more about your
negotiation experience
with the publisher in order to get their
article for one
dollar per month since i am building a
startup
and i'm going to negotiate with the
vendors
and i don't know where to start you know
yeah
yeah so the question is like how do you
kind of negotiate with publishers or
vendors
it's really hard like it's it's it's uh
so we tried it when we were really small
and like nobody like paid attention to
us
um and so we just dropped it we decided
we're not gonna even
bother talking to publishers and so the
first year and a half actually we did
not talk to publishers we just
focused on getting uh you know there was
a lot of enough
kind of public rss feeds out there kind
of public content out there
and so we decided we're not going to
talk to publishers we're just going to
like try to build an audience
first and see if people if we can
convince enough people to actually
download pulse and use the content
and actually read the content here when
we got to about you know a couple
million users like three four million
users
publishers started reaching out to us
and they said i actually want to be part
of pulse because i want to actually
expand my audience
um and so we just kind of did that for a
while
until we actually raised our series and
then we actually built a team which does
more outreach and actually gets more
publishers
but actually if you can actually create
a scenario
sorry this is a non-answer but if you
can create a scenario where
um they need you more than you need them
um then you're kind of in a good
position
and which is usually when you focus on
the product
right like it all comes back to what is
your mission
what are your values and what is your
product actually doing
and it's possible like i think for us at
least i don't know what your business is
but
for us like we kind of had to hack
around a lot of different things to make
that possible
um but you know i think
from their perspective also you can
think that for a publisher they might be
getting pitched you know a thousand
ideas every day and so they can't really
talk to thousand companies but when they
see a company that's really kind of
growing then they have to talk to them
right a little bit more
how could you assign the first content
so most of the content
i mean i copied right right and there's
a lot of public content public feeds
available
um so a lot of tech blogs a lot of small
blogs are available
freely that you can use so we kind of
like
you know did whatever we could with the
content we had available
before and now we have partnerships with
over
750 publishers but initially we did not
focus on that that much we just focused
on building a great product that people
could use to read
did you face any legal problems while
you were following
those problems related to incorporation
and all these uh
between international performances i'd
get lost because i think
we got sued by new york times then i
think very early on
yeah i think related to visa stuff we
were lucky we were students we were on a
student visa
we put the company on e-verify so we
could actually work for another 15
months
after like 29 months or something
so that was that was easy if you're
starting off as a student
and i think the biggest advice like you
should definitely incorporate your
company
and and get get all that going as soon
as you
as soon as you can because that really
helps you if you want to
start monetizing and you're on a on a
student visa
you know you can start doing that or it
also and lends
kind of a legitimacy to what i'm doing
and and prevents you from giving up i'm
just going to add a disclaimer there you
should talk to
like immigration lawyers and tax lawyers
uh do not take our word for it
but i think it's possible we can connect
you with some people yeah
but actually on the legal side we did
have a really
fascinating day in june i think we were
still in school
so this was after the new york times
actually wrote about us and uh
that was more on the editorial side and
so but i think
this was monday i think it was sometime
in june early june
it was the wwdc conference and steve
jobs was
going to actually release the iphone 4
which was a huge improvement and then
before he actually launched the iphone 4
he talked about five or six
apps that he loves and we had no idea
apple doesn't tell you anything until
you actually see it and so i was
watching this
in the dorm here and ankit was actually
in new york
and so he's like oh let me show you some
ipad apps that i like
and there we were you were the first you
know pulse was the first app that he
talked about
and i was just like did that really
happen
why am i dreaming here but anyway so
this is like 10 a.m
monday morning i'm kind of going berserk
this is probably like the highest tie
uh it's probably like the you know
happiest i've ever been
come like maybe five hours later three
or three o'clock 3 30 to be precise
um ankit and i get an email from apple
saying that
um you know new york times has
complained and we've taken your app out
of the
store five hours later so so when you
did when they talk about roller coaster
you know the
entrepreneur's life being a roller
coaster that happened in five hours
um i think a lot of things that happened
and then we were back into the store
next
the next day morning uh but that was
that was one of the
craziest mondays i've ever had we've
ever had
so you raised a very interesting
question about luck
that you guys were lucky so in your
opinion what would you honestly say was
luck versus something that
you learned like skill from all the
experiences
i think we may have different views to
me yeah maybe both of us can actually
talk
uh well i think i mean luck is very
ambiguous
uh because to me
a lot of what luck is is just your
subconscious
algorithms that you develop
which could be skills that you might
know or might not know of
but throughout a lot of these side
projects throughout
kind of just thinking through things
deeply there's a lot of things that you
develop that
uh you base your decisions upon
and that's intuition or that's good or
whatever and that
makes you feel lucky because you chose
this based on very little data and was
like oh i was lucky i came to stanford
uh that kind of thing or i was lucky i
took this d-school class that that
launched pulse
um but but there's obviously that's not
all of it i think there's there's real
real luck uh which could be
you know meeting akshay in the first
first week of school
uh or just like a lot of uh
yeah there are those moments um or
you know being being mentioned by steve
jobs i guess
yeah i think like it's i think a lot a
lot
i actually attribute a lot of pulse to
like good timing
um good luck i think uh but i think
actually you can create that for you
like i think it's i think of it as more
like
you know you're at a bar and there's
like you can play darts and you just
kind of
keep throwing darts like sometimes
you'll hit the bull's eye
and so i actually think you can create
that but if you don't play darts like i
don't know if you ever hit the bullseye
but actually with pulse there was a lot
of good timing like ipad had just come
out
and we were one of the early news apps
we were written about in new york times
and so we were on the top of the app
store that was probably the time that
steve jobs was probably thinking about
like what
what are the apps that i want to
actually talk about and so just being on
the top of the app store
just that day before he actually talks
about it was i don't know
probably got send um
well there's that interesting anecdote
with uh was that newspaper app
uh yeah there was also editions
there was also a competitor back then um
whom you i think there was a small
company and i think we were both
fighting to like
stay ahead of each other in news
category and
uh i think we both pushed our app
updates at the same time
i think we got approved and then i think
the other developer um
i guess got delayed or felt thick or
something and then that was like
just a day difference where i think
pulse got picked up and then it was you
know on the top of the store
i think a lot of things have happened
like i think we were lucky uh to be out
on android first when
amazon actually picked us as one of the
apps they wanted to put on their kindle
fire
uh it was just like being at the right
place at the right time like
you can't really like hope for that but
i think you can try different things and
hopefully like some things work out but
i think you know i think we've tried
really hard but i think it would be
false to say that you know everything is
because of our hard work i think a lot
of it was good timing
a lot of it was luck a lot of it was
kind of meant to be
one more question can you describe a
little bit more about
your launch strategy and how you got to
be noticed i know you guys talked a
little bit about
posting on design blogs but how were you
guys
um approaching trying to get noticed by
people and what did you really do
so the question is about how we uh
what's our strategy to get noticed
yes um i think
this the strategy is actually actually
evolving every day
it started with posting videos on on
design blogs but
i don't think we can honestly say that
we have it down
and and we know what the strategy is uh
i think one thing i can definitely say
and
we can add to that is uh we we realized
very early on that you need to be
a you need to be very focused on your
product because your product speaks
much more than than any kind of press
that you get or any other
publicity that you get and and b you
need to be able to
have the right focus for that product
and so who is the user what is the need
that you're solving with that product
and what is how does that product help
someone's life and so when i am a
passionate user of pulse
and i go to my friend how do i tell how
do i convince them to download pulse
and and and set it up right then what do
i say and all of that comes from
the the founders and the team being very
focused on this one thing
that that we're trying to solve and that
basically drives itself uh
well that's that's the current working
hypothesis i think the other
i guess like one thing i read recently
that i liked a lot was essentially
don't think of it as a launch like i
think like we have this idea in our
heads that
we are you know working on this thing
for months or weeks and we're gonna have
a launch but if you like take that
stress away from you
just kind of push it out see how people
are using like even if you have 100
people really engaged
and using it
one of the things we did in pulse and
totally through luck
but you know it wasn't planned but when
we first pushed out our
uh pushed out the app live on app store
the first version of the app
actually had this heart sign on the top
right uh
we we you know that heart sign was
you know people thought well maybe you
like the app or maybe you do that
when you click on that heart sign on the
app it would open up this
inbox kind of a composed mailbox compose
mail
directed to us with the subject feedback
for pulse
and people all they needed to do was
have to type something in and so even if
people kind of
like by mistake clicked on that they
sent us some interesting feedback
and like a lot of people may actually
send you like oh this app is good
or this app sucks or something like that
but some you know one out of 10 meals
was actually like
people doing work for you they would be
like you know this visual design is
really bad you should try this color and
we were like holy people are
actually telling us
what color we should use here or like
people actually telling us hey i really
want to read this this and this
and remember for the first four or five
weeks ankit and i actually painfully
read every email responded to every
email
got into a discussion there was that one
really big email from
a neuroscientist who actually told us
that
the design we have is so good that our
brain can really
visualize a lot of content this is the
most efficient design for the brain to
kind of
actually like skim through content and
you're like yeah we exactly thought
about that
but i think like the key is like you
know even if you have only 100 people
but they're really engaged
um then you can actually get to a point
where hopefully you are actually
tracking data you can actually look at
analytics and you can actually figure
out like
hey this is why people are so engaged if
we do this we may be able to get
a bunch of other people also engaged but
try to remove that stress of being
launched because
i think we can tell you our numbers like
when people write about you in
techcrunch or new york times or other
things
you're going to see a spike no question
about it you're going to
see 10 times 20 times 100 times more
downloads than anybody else
but those downloads let's say if i got a
thousand dollars or every day
and because i wasn't in techcrunch we
got like 50 000 downloads
those 50 000 downloads are not people
who will
most likely be using your app three
months from now there are the people who
kind of read about it downloaded it and
probably like deleted the app
but i think the people who can actually
use about it use your product people who
actually discover it
uh and actually liked it and actually
told their friends about it you know
those are the people who will stick with
their product those are the people who
will actually
make you make your product and make your
company a lot more successful
rather than the people who kind of just
read about it in techcrunch today
downloaded it and then through it
so try to remove that launch stress away
just push things out there see what
people say
kind of build on top of that
do we have one we
invite everybody to come uh talk to them
afterwards and ask questions but
on behalf of sdvp driver fischer
jefferson stanford bases and all of us
here at stanford today
thank you for joining us thank you